l'internet oui alors donc on commence
sur commence par moi ok alors donc dans
quelques instants on va s'intéresser à
un sujet dont on ne voudrait pas
s'intéresser à sûr pas parler d'un mot
qui ne devrait pas exister le mot
racisme voilà donc c'est ça avec nos
invités ou india et maïté c'est bon pour
toi
maïté à toi oui prochain chantier
isabelle et paul oui c'est ça elle est à
québec
ah oui aie aie aie aie pas au ccc celui
de qualité qui est trop longue
les deux titres sont trop lents qui
attend vas-y dix mois les je vais te
dire quoi couper
[Musique]
ok alors pour maïté tu vas dire
chroniqueuse au journal métro journal j
majuscule métro m majuscule
ça sera la seule chose qu'on va mettre
là parce qu'on pourra pas le mettre le
reste mais on la présentera tout à
l'heure comme il faut ça ne va pas été
oui ok j'ai vu le oui je t'entends pas
mais j'ai vu le oui ok maïté est-ce que
tu l'as vu le documentaire katapult en
hockey parfait juste ne sachant c'est
correct comme ça je te poserait pas de
questions sur le documentaire comme tel
oui oui je le parle pas en ce moment
mike est ce que tu peux juste me parler
à huy parfait je tenterais bien ok je
suis un excellent ah ouais parfait merci
ok il pour wii dias que c'est trop long
aussi de quoi on sait pas ce que je t'ai
envoyé mes trucs à moi ok pour louisiens
vasily moi ce que ce qui est écrit
l'endroit était ok qu'est ce que tu
voudrais qu'on écrive oui dia il faut
avoir un titre qui m'a cofondatrice de
mick hannah mikana m majuscule ycaa m ah
oui c'est ça
voilà puis isabelle elle nous en temps
ils nous on va pouvoir l'entendre aussi
a pas de souci pour ça c'est bon et puis
maïté elle est en skype
à l'autre bout est ce que tu en toile sa
belle
bonjour mais moi je l'entends pas maïté
par contre je l'entendais tout à l'heure
ça c'est bon
ils m'ont dit qu'ils faisaient des tests
de son
c'est pas
[Musique]
vous voyez à mes côtés je n'ai pas
isabelle aujourd'hui mais isabelle n'est
pas très loin vous allez voir on va
aller la retrouver dans quelques
instants
aujourd'hui nous allons parler d'une
manifestation humaine qui s'appelle le
racisme et je le dis parce que cette
manifestation ne devrait pas exister ce
mot n'aurait jamais dû être inventés et
ceux qui en sont victimes sont les
personnes racisées très souvent et les
personnes autochtones
alors pourquoi est ce que c'est le cas
comment est-ce qu'on peut changer les
choses c'est ce dont nous allons
discuter au cours des prochaines minutes
avec nos invités alors qu'isabelle n'est
pas à côté je vous le disais mais c'est
oui dit à la rivière bonjour india
oui oui dia je vais prendre mes lunettes
je vais prendre parce que j'ai tellement
de choses à dire sur vous vous êtes
éducatrice en droits humains et droits
des peuples autochtones
vous êtes la cofondatrice de mika n'a
donc ça nos organismes qui veut
sensibiliser sur les réalités
autochtones c'est bien ça vous êtes à
coup une initiatrice de la mobilisation
aux québécoises du mouvement idol noir
avec mélissa mollen dupuis vous est
ambassadrice de la conscience d'amnistié
internationale vous êtes aux tris et
vous êtes cinéaste et j'ajouterais vous
êtes une fière anishnabe originaire de
la communauté de timiskaming en
abitibi-témiscamingue parfait maintenant
en skype nous avons maïté labrecque
saganash bonjour maïté merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs avant d'aller plus loin vous
êtes louer ou là physiquement en ce
moment d'accord alors ouais swan
hippiques qui est votre communauté
d'origine parce que vous êtes une fière
cris n'est ce pas originaire donc de la
communauté de waswanipi situés en ue et
she baie james donc dans le nord du
québec
maïté vous êtes technicienne aux
communications du conseil de la santé
crise est bien sa voix là et vous êtes
chroniqueuse pour le journal métro on a
un petit son qui nous arrive attendez on
va le
laisser partir voilà alors merci maïté
d'être là et puis nous allons aller à
québec c'est là que se trouve notre
collègue chroniqueuse également
ethnologue isabelle picard bonjour
isabelle vous êtes l'arroseur oui voilà
alors voilà oui je vous vois on va le
rappeler vous êtes une fière wendat
originaire de fouine dac et dans la
région de québec
et c'est justement à québec que vous
êtes aujourd'hui
alors j'ai intitulé cette émission-là
haro sur le racisme envers les
autochtones parce qu'on est même si on
est en 2020 vous êtes encore toutes les
trois victimes de racisme
est-ce qu'on pourrait y aller avec des
exemples concrets ce que vous pourriez
nous expliquer des situations dans
lesquelles vous en faites des situations
que vous avez vécu dans lesquelles vous
étiez impliqués et où vous avez senti du
racisme envers vous on va commencer à
lekhwiya
ouais mais moi j'aimerais quand même
commencé par dire que je suis quand même
privilégié parce que j'ai ce qu'on
appelle le privilège de passe de la
white passing je pense en anglais donc
j'ai pas nécessairement vivent leur
expliquer ce que c'est
en fait c'est que je ne peux pas assez
pour une passe d'une personne blanche où
il est les gens vont pas nécessairement
savoir tout de suite une personne
autochtone et ben ça ça m'a quand même
éviter certaines situations de racisme
que certains confrères conservateurs
tonnes peuvent avoir vécu notamment
parce que les gens de suite les ont
identifiés comme autochtone que ce soit
par la couleur de la peau un accent qui
parle en français la même chose si pour
l'accent donc j'aimerais quand même
enseigné comme différents types de
raciste qui vécut puis que même entre
autochtone les véhicules quand même
différemment d'une personne à l'autre
mais tout ce que je peux dire dans mon
entourage sait que le racisme envers les
autochtones se manifestent vraiment de
différentes manières que ce soit
plus globalement la discrimination qui
cherchent un logement dans l'emploi la
surreprésentation des enfants
autochtones dans les services de
protection de la jeunesse
on a vu aussi dernièrement la
surreprésentation des femmes autochtones
encore dans un pénitencier
donc c'est vraiment et de peut-être plus
haut niveau systémique de queue
qu'on parle dans ces cas-ci
mais dans le cas en fait du documentaire
briser les codes
il ya des données montrer aussi que le
raciste c'est manifeste vraiment aussi
de manière c'est pas toujours de manière
décomplexée mais de manière plus subtile
oui c'est ce qui va venir par exemple
affecté notre vie quotidienne pour ça
aussi par exemple
moi même je peux je peux je l'aï vécu
quand même à quelques reprises de devoir
comme adapter mon comportement
certains - justin makoun mutuelle
labeaume devant c'est amusant parce
qu'on en a pas encore parlé et on va en
parler dans quelques instants on va
d'abord écouté l'expérience ou les
expériences qu aurait vécu maïté des
expériences de racisme à votre encontre
maïté c'était un peu la même chose mais
bon moi j'habitais de centres urbains où
il ya beaucoup d'autochtones donc c'est
parfois je me fais identifier puis ça
peut prendre ça peut prendre plusieurs
formes des fois bon je peux me faire
suivre dans un commerce
des fois il ya des gens qui est bon qui
veut se pencher qu'ils entretiennent
mais ça peut aussi prendre des formes
plus les mecs comme l'ont mentionné au i
10 heures puis moi bonjour j'ai beaucoup
j'ai beaucoup vécu de bons écrivains
journal métro aussi bon j'ai reçu
beaucoup de commentaires quand j'ai été
exposé en étant une jeune femme
autochtone je pense j'ai exposés à
beaucoup de ce qu'on appelle des trolls
mais bon pas mais plus d'opposition des
gens qui s'amusaient rameurs seul et sur
les réseaux sociaux puis sortait d d d d
insultes racistes ou bon dire des choses
comme au mec est quand même belle pour
une indienne ailleurs oui donc donc
comme le mode comme le mentionnait un
média de race et ça prend plusieurs
formes
moi je pense que c'est beau c'est
beaucoup cette marque isabelle de votre
côté je vous pose la question aussi
est-ce que vous avez été victime de
racisme
en tant que femme autochtone oui oui
absolument ça m'est arrivé déjà dans le
passé les premières fois directe devait
avoir environ 13
1 c'était juste après la crise d'oka
donc quand je suis revenue à l'école
secondaire j'étais en secondaire 2 et là
j'ai eu le droit à une panoplie de bon
ton père vendu des cigarettes de tud et
les stéréotypes le qu'on peut avoir à
propos des autochtones tu vas tu nous
faire une barricade bon des trucs comme
ça je les ai à peu près tout entendu de
monnaies à plus récentes je dirais que
en petit il ya quatre ans j'ai acheté
une maison à montréal et je la raconte
souvent cette anecdote lamé et je pense
qu'on parle de petites choses ça
s'inscrit à l'intérieur de ça la dame
qui me vendait la maison une québécoise
me demandez pas ce que j'aurais pu comme
me dit ah je peux également pas assez
pour une blanche et elle n'était pas
certaine et le disque était italienne et
j'ai dit non je ne suis pas italienne je
suis autochtone et elle m'a répondu bah
écoute c'est peut-être mieux de paul
mentionné au voisin que tu es autochtone
donc ça c'est quelque chose que j'ai
entendu et on a souvent également
surveiller ma consommation d'alcool ça
m'est déjà arrivé
j'étais célibataire je rencontrais des
hommes et puis là au bout de deux verres
ils vérifiaient les dons qu'ils posaient
des questions là-dessus on part avec
certains stéréotypes certains préjugés
je pense comme comme autochtone en fait
il ya tellement d'ignorance et je pense
que le racisme est souvent lié aussi à
l'ignorance ou izia
ben oui totalement c'est en fait c'est
une des causes principales du racisme
c'est justement la méconnaissance ou la
peur de l'étranger
quand on est différent actuellement bon
s'inquiète c'est un étranger entre
guillemets je le dis la peur de
l'étranger mais aussi donc de laisser en
partie d'ignorance oui tout à fait tafer
mois puis en fait encore aujourd'hui
mais il ya quand même une nette hausse
de prise de conscience collective pas
d'apport de société québécoise envers
les questions de tonnes mais il ya
encore beaucoup de chemin à faire puis
justement ce matin je disais l'histoire
d'une jeune attikameks qui joue en
équipe qui est victimes quotidiennement
de propos racistes qu'il y avait joué
dans d'autres villes dans des gammes de
rock et ya encore beaucoup d'eux et
c'est ça m'amène justement ce
documentaire briser le code de fabrice
ville un documentaire qui a été diffusée
sur télé québec au cours des derniers
jours le jeudi soir je pense ou mercredi
soir le 29 ou en 1031 et donc qui met en
scène quatre personnes trois personnes
assises et donc
d'ailleurs je pense qu'elles sont toutes
nées au québec mais de parents venus
d'ailleurs elles ont un accent ou
différent où elles ont un look différent
et donc elles sont on les considère
comme des étrangers un des personnes
venues d'ailleurs alors qu'elles sont
vraiment né ici et une personnes
autochtones
alexandre volant qui vient de pessamit
tu est donc lui est autochtone et qui
vit lui aussi ce racisme latent qu'il
peut rencontrer dans la rue à l'école
avec n'importe où finalement parce que
c'est ça le racisme il est partout
nessma oui tout à fait puis ben c'est ça
qu'est ce qu'on a vu dans fait plus
spécifiquement ou que d'alexandre dans
le documentaire se sait que buffett lui
ses saillies partie de la communauté de
pessamit pour aller vivre à forestville
et à ce moment là qu'a commencé à
développer ici ces mécanismes de défense
en fait comme ça c'est pour ça que le
documentaire s'appelle briser le code
parce qu'il lui même
je pense aujourd'hui essaye de briser ce
code
alors j'avais trouvé une définition
intéressante de briser le code c'est
amener les personnes racisées ou
autochtone à adopter des attitudes et
comportements pour se fondre à la
majorité oui est ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous avez déjà fait oui dia
briser le colloque ou au contraire
est-ce que vous êtes déjà entrée dans le
code vous avez suivi le code
ouais mais en fait avant même que
j'apprenne à mettre beaucoup sur ce cas
c'est le cas depuis ces mécanismes de
défense de mais oui en pensant je pense
que j'ai vraiment fait absolue dans ma
vie et aussi parce que comme je parlais
tantôt avec mon privilège de passe bien
c'est plus facile pour moi de cacher que
je suis autochtone donc c'est par
exemple déjà arrivé que je vois dans un
discours voiturage maintenant avec amigo
express puis de cette journée là ça me
tente pas vraiment de de faire un cours
autochtones sont engagés fait que l'eau
quand les gens me demandent à william
parce que ce soit c'est à travers mon
prénom quand même six days assez de ça
veut dire quoi c'était une origine
particulière puis à certains moments
c'est ce que j'ai déjà dit caché que
c'était un prénom and china b parce que
je ne supportais pas de commencer à
expliquer pendant tout le long du trajet
oui les réalités autochtones puis parce
que c'est quand même épuisant de porter
sur ses épaules mais ce sont les
ducation que la sensibilisation et
quotidienne son ordinateur d'acton parce
que c'est un thème encore de l'ignorance
et de méconnaissance
donc oui j'ai comme réa duc qui a eu
plusieurs situations comme ça au flicage
et utiliser le code
aujourd'hui je suis plus conscient
depuis donc je sais c'est sûr que d'y
penser ça qu'on essaie de le briser mais
en même temps c'est pas le rehaussement
des gens qui attaquent utilise le code
de de briser les idées les gens qui font
des commentaires aux gens qui ont des
propos qui est un peu plus conscients de
ce qu'ils disent
maïté maïté est-ce que vous avez déjà eu
à emprunter le code là pour passer
inaperçus ou ne pas trop vous faire
remarquer absolument je pense que ça le
pré salé pris forme surtout dans les
prises de position que j'avais dont je
voulais pas je voulais pas faire trop de
remous puis je voulais faire essayer
lieu certaines choses que vous sortez ce
sujet sur lequel j'écris que ça passe
moins bien donc devenu une forme aussi
de thau censure avec c'est donc qu'il ya
des journées où ça me tente pas de
recevoir des tweets méchaal est
aujourd'hui ça me paraît donc oui non
absolument il fallut que même encore
aujourd'hui à des fois où ce que
j'aimerais écrire sur certains sujets
mais je ne peux pas donc aubin sam tente
juste un oui mais non est absolument
puis je pense que je pense que tout le
monde
aussi certaines voies de service à la
clientèle russie j'avais déjà vu dans ma
communauté donc certains bouillon de
certains soins qu'on utilise souvent il
ya certaines certaines expressions qu'on
est habitué aux sorties naksa aussi
qu'on a un contenu en anglais dans la
réserve mais que je ne vais adopter que
je n'adopte pas quand je suis à la
télévision quand je suis au téléphone
quand j'en appelle un porteur que des
entrevues mais je pense que ce code le
sam bon de travailler aussi dans un
institution qui écrit avec des avec
d'autres qui je pense que ça m'a aidé
aussi à
a un peu brisé cinq fois dans ma vie
personnelle parce que je travaille avec
mon père je travaille pour mon père
aussi
et donc j'ai pas besoin d'eux j'ai pas
besoin de plaire à qui compte en fait je
travaille juste pour ma communauté du
travail condamnation et isabelle de
votre côté est ce que vous même vous
avez endossé le code pour passer
inaperçu ah oui ah oui absolument
surtout plus jeune je dirais pour des
emplois en particulier qui était pas
j'ai travaillé autant des organisations
autochtones que dans des non autochtones
et je me suis aperçu rapidement que je
ne fonctionnait pas de la même manière
quand je travaillais pour la ville de
montréal par exemple ou pour un
gouvernement exclut y
il ya des manières de faire qui étaient
étaient différentes et aussi beaucoup
dans l'umoa homos c'est dans l'humour
que je vois mon humour est différent
quand je suis entouré de personnes
autochtones que quand je vais être à
l'extérieur on devrait quand nous notre
humour autochtone et très on est
beaucoup dans l'autodérision n'est en
rien un peu désordre mais c'est pas
méchant une manière de le faire qu'ils
aient eu quelques bienveillante sa
l'extérieur ça passe moins bien donc
dans mon réseau social qui est non
autochtone
aussi je vais changer ça pousse même
adapté finalement au code
oui lors du dépôt du rapport vient donc
cette grande commission qui a été tenu
au québec au cours des deux dernières
années qui a été déposée en septembre
dernier le juge vient parlait de
discrimination il parlait pas de racisme
est en fait ghislain picard le chef de
la pnq est la maman données du avait dit
regardez mehmet mettons les bons mots
sur les bonnes affaires il est question
aussi de racisme et dans la société
qu'elle soit québécoises ou canadiennes
on parle beaucoup de ce raciste de
racisme systémique alors isabelle me
tourne vers vous le racisme systémique
c'est quoi exactement
mais en fait si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
je pense que c'est le système tout ce
qui compose le système ses lois ses
politiques dans ces programmes la
manière dont il est il a été bâti même
ses fondements qui vont faire en sorte
que un groupe donné
soit par bon niveau sa race nommément
vont être traités à part va être traité
en particulier évidemment on pense aux
autochtones dans un cas comme celui là
entre autres la loi sont les indiens va
faire en sorte que les autochtones vont
être traitées et tout ce qu'ils savent
tout ce qui en découle bien sûr va faire
en sorte que les autochtones doit avoir
une place à part dans la société
donc en lien avec cette loi donne
notamment
ok alors on pour y revenir au rapport
vient justement lors de la commission
vient il y avait là l'observatrice
indépendant de fannie lafontaine qui en
avait parlé du racisme elle même a été
une des premières je pense à aborder ce
thème là oui tout à fait en fait madame
la fontaine c'est en 2016 en novembre
2016 qu'elle a déposé son premier
rapport on se souvient qu'elle était
observatrice indépendante dans le cadre
de l'enfer valda avec les policiers et
elle avait nommé ça a été la première à
nommer les choses c'est à dire oui j'ai
pu observer qu'il y avait une culture de
racisme systémique au niveau des corps
policiers plus précisément peut-être à
val-d'or et on fait le rapport vient il
venu un peu confirmé bien qu'il ait
parlé davantage de discriminations mais
il ya quand même également avec bon les
témoignages le cul pendant la commission
il a pu voir qu'il y avait quand même
une culture de discrimination à tout le
moins systémique le haut niveau du
gouvernement québécois
voilà donc on n'ose prononcer le mot
maintenant et pourtant les exemples de
racisme qui soit systémique ou au
travers les autochtones
on en voit pratiquement tous les jours
bon j'exagère parce qu'ils ne sont pas
dans les médias tous les jours mais
j'imagine que j'exagère pas parce que
dans la réalité les autochtones les les
îles les inuit qu'il soit inuit qu'il
soit première nation ou métis le vivent
chacun à leur manière un peu tous les
jours n'est ce pas isabelle oui oui tout
à fait mais en faire quand on parle de
racisme souvent on s'imagine il ya des
gens qui vont s'imaginer automatiquement
qu'on parle d' antisémitisme ou de
crimes haineux ou quelque chose de
violent mais le racisme s'apprête
racisme ordinaire
du racisme de tous les jours des petites
choses qui va partir de préjugés et de
stéréotypes
ça peut être la peur de l'autre ça peut
être aussi vous savez la colonisation a
été basée ça c'est quand même assez
intéressant mais c'est basé sur le fait
qu' il ya un peuple qui est supérieur à
l'autre et donc quand les européens sont
arrivés ici bâillon nie et le peuplement
déjà existants sur le territoire
donc cette hiérarchie fait partie aussi
c'est une forme de racisme également
bien sûr la n va être un des facteurs
l'intolérance également va être un des
facteurs le qui vont amener du racisme
donc le racisme s'est inscrit aussi pour
seulement dans les grandes choses mais
aussi dans les petites choses du
quotidien
on pourrait donner des exemples vous
dire vous en avez donné avant qu'on
entre en nom de la vous m'avez parlé d'
un exemple assez concret merci jeune
hockeyeuse oui c'est ça oui bah une
jeune femme attikameks est sorti dans
les nouvelles ce matin une jeune femme
attikameks assez commun même temps dans
le documentaire
c'est un complément de partie 2-2 requis
mais ouais c'est ça une jeune femme
attikameks qui est victime de propos
racistes
quand elle veut jouer au hockey dans la
ville de par exemple de saint félicien
donc oui ça se sait des propos à nuancer
c'est comme une autre manifestation a
fait preuve de racisme puis pour revenir
un peu sur la différence entre assises
discrimination raciste c'est plus une
question de l'idéologie d'attitude et de
mentalité et la discrimation sait plus
comment ça se manifeste dans nos
comportements donc la discrimination en
fête d'école balade carnation raciale
par exemple découle du régime c'est
quand même un temps interdit oui oui
maïté là vous êtes vous êtes à waswanipi
mais sinon vous êtes aussi ailleurs un
peu partout sur le territoire
est ce que le racisme envers vous envers
votre communauté ou les communautés en
général sont plus fréquentes en région
en milieu urbain
je dirais que je dirais que c'est moitié
moitié et moi j'habitais à montréal avec
qui j'en aï subi j'en ai subi la nation
fondée subi des comportements racistes
puis moi j'étais j'ai témoigné
d'ailleurs à la commission vient comme
ça compte des services policiers en trop
qui moi bon je suis déménagé dans ma
communauté
surtout pas en fait pour éviter puis je
pense aussi que à montréal ça prenait
une forme un peu plus un peu plus
insidieusement surtout quand j'étais
invité à donner des présentations dans
des écoles les choses comme ça où les
gens me demandaient de faire ce
bénévolement de faire l'éducation
d'aider à propos des peuples autochtones
bénévolement je pense que c'est qu'ils
me payer moins que dont personne qui les
invitait ce je pense que j'ai envie aux
gens vivaient beaucoup puis à un moment
donné bon cgt un peu le token csa prend
une personne autochtone je pense qu'on a
toutes mes pistes et pour ça en fait que
je suis de nager de c'est une des
raisons pourquoi je suis déménagé en
communauté parce que j'avais je n'avais
plus envie d'expliquer ma culture mon
origine tout le temps puis je voulais la
vivre ma culture au lieu de l'a2 au lieu
de l'expliquer puis donc si ça donc
c'est pour ça que je suis est réductrice
ccir et comporte en date avec la dette
avec ses pales donc c'est pour ça que je
suis revenue mais voudrait que en région
bon peut-être que ça prend ça prend deux
formes mesurer que la même chose alors
en tout cas j'espère que vous n'étiez
pas sollicité bénévolement pour
travailler aux capsules que vous avez
préparé non liens avec eux briser le
code parce qu'il ya le documentaire
briser le code il ya un balado je pense
et il ya aussi des capsules auquel
plusieurs personnes ont participé dont
vous vous en avez préparé trois ou
quatre ans je les ai noté le 20 janvier
par les couacs y en ait trois ou deux
que j'en aime moi même puis j'en ai j'en
ai une autre qu'on est les trois
animateurs voilà
alors une entre autres qui s'appelle
appropriation culturel donc démystifier
un peu c'est quoi le concept
d'appropriation culturel
il ya aussi les biais inconscient donc
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a des biens est un
con sen inconscient et comment on
devrait les reconnaître et puis il ya
autochtone 102 la sepa autochtone 100m
autochtone 110-102 parce que vous pensez
que déjà les gens connaissent un petit
peu sur les autochtones mais c'est juste
qu'on devrait être rendue je pense que
je pense qu'on devrait être rendu à
certains standards moi moi j'attends que
les gens ne le pensent pas que je paie
pas de taxes partout n'importe quand je
pense que la partie je pense que la
sphère des taxes la sphère des mots
comme indien au cas où ils ont en eux je
pense qu'on en a parlé beaucoup piste
est un peu je pense campagne une tasse
une frustration le convie fréquemment de
voir d'autres expliquer ces concepts
simples à outrance
nous on a un nom on assume que c'est
déjà enregistré de toute façon il ya eu
amplement d'informations disponibles là
dessus sur internet dans les journaux
est rejetée va donc nous on a décidé de
faire un peu d'aller un peu plus loin
alors je vais juste faire un petit
commentaire est dommage par continent
quelques outils incontournables dont
espace autochtone parce qu'on montre les
ressources auxquelles on peut se référer
pour aller voir pour en apprendre plus
sur les autochtones et c'est dommage
j'ai pas vu et qui tienne j'ai pas vu
six piscines d'aedgency be seen orthez
j'ai pas vu un espace autochtones qui
sont quand même des ressources vraiment
une mine d'informations sur des réalités
autochtones en apprendre plus alors
voilà c'était mon petit commentaire mais
sinon oui les les capsules est ce que
vous allez en faire d'autres est-ce
qu'il y en a déjà trois qui en aura plus
que ça moi c'est tout ce qu'on m'a
demandé le les capsules moi j'ai c'est
juste que l'uci qui a écrit les textes
et on les aurait visé chacun nous les a
remises et que les adapter aux
et par la suite mais n'ont pour le
moment je récitais tout j'espère en
faire d'autres si jamais une opportunité
se présente demeurer sera excellente en
plus passion vous les avez fait avec
beaucoup d'humour ce qui dédramatise
aussi le sujet parce que c'est des
sujets qui ne sont pas évidents et le
faire passer avec humour
c'est peut-être une façon idéale aussi
pour aller atteindre les gens exactement
puis nous on voulait on voulait cibler
un auditoire qui est assez jeunes aussi
qui c'est pour ça qu'on est allé à
autochtone sans doute parce que je pense
qu'elle est je pense que la plus jeune
génération seront plus sensibles à ces
questions là en apprennent un petit peu
plus à l'école même si bon c'est le
curriculum et pas encore parfait l'on
s'entend mais je pense que dans ce sens
ils en apprennent plus que la génération
donc c'est pour ça que je pense que
l'humour façon désamorcer les choses de
mieux faire passer un message aussi ils
vont vous avez vu les capsules il ya
beaucoup d'aidé dedans on insère des
segments qui sont drôles on a les sabots
vidéo donc c'est super n'insiste pas
donc si jamais vous la laissiez briser
les feux nous encouragent oui elles sont
très très bien fait ces capsules
absolument donc elles sont disponibles
sur le site de télé québec
ça vaut vraiment la peine d'aller
d'aller les consulter parlons des jeunes
justement est ce que les jeunes ont
intégré déjà le code weeds ya comme un
chien oui les jeunes autochtones parce
que alexandre volant en parlait lui dis
bon ben moi j'ai brisé le code
maintenant on le voit dans le
documentaire il dit maintenant j'ai
envie d'aller parler aux jeunes pour
leur dire hey il ne tombait pas là
dedans
ouais je pense que je peux pas parler
pour tous les jeunes mais je pense qu'en
oui effectivement
on vit je pense un peu tous à différents
niveaux qui certaines personnes vont
peut-être avoir tous besoin de ces
mécanismes de défense pour se protéger
justement des gens qui vivent comme
telle puce de racisme de discrimination
que timo peut-être développer un peu
plus ces mécanismes parce que ce sont
des en fait des mécanismes de défense
bien sûr mais protection aussi on se
protège
ouais c'est ça mais mr fin en fait de
faux comme essayer de renverser tous
appuyé de se dire que comme moi des fois
j'essaie de me dire qui j'aimerais ça
comme un peu pour faire dispose sur ce
qu'elle m'a été dit et comme je me sois
passé plus de temps à aimer ma culture
et mon peuple et mimi coframi concert
qui est de passer du temps à détester le
racisme et le colonialisme puis ses sept
enfants
je pense que moyen de contrer tous en
fait le code ses deux assesseurs
d'essayer de valoriser sa culture de
travail
revaloriser son identité je pense que
les jeunes autochtones sont aussi très
inventif à ce niveau benoît sont parce
qu'en fait une culture c'est ça a évolué
avec le temps qui je pense que les
joueurs docteur son site web
bien placé pour pouvoir justement
réinventer puis faire évoluer les
cultures autochtones je pensais là
dessus aussi qu'il faut se concentrer
pour essayer de trouver de quoi est-ce
que avec mick hannah est ce que c'est ce
que vous faites
oui ben en fait une des grandes
activités de mécano c'est d'appliquer
justement déjà un autochtone dans
l'éducation sur la sensibilisation sur
les réalités de tonnes puis on essaie en
même temps et justement que ce soit pour
les jeunes autochtones
une manière de
valoriser nos histoires de valoriser
marié de faire un peu de l'âme permet en
fait parce que pas seulement comme
éduqués pour indiquer oui c'est
important si pour ne pas se faire ce
travail de comment vous le faites c'est
concrètement donnez moi des exemples
éviter que vous organisez on a même
beaucoup des ateliers mais qui vont au
delà des ateliers disons classique de
magistrats
on essaye beaucoup de femmes des
ateliers interactifs pierre est un que
j'ai eu ben j'avais eu la chance
notamment de commencer à la prendre
quand j'étais chez les femmes
autochtones du québec et c'est un jeu de
rôle qui s'appelle le circuit la boîte
dans lesquelles les gens elle joue un
rôle dans une société autochtone
précoloniale dans le cercle puis à la
fin d'atelier comme une narration sur
l'histoire de la colonisation et à la
fin ça se termine encore et donc avec le
système des conseils de bande puis la
manière occidentale de
de fonctionnement donc c'est comme
trouver d'autres moyens de celui de
sensibiliser les gens qu'ils rendent
souci un peu plus passer sur interactif
s'inspirer aussi de culture l'histoire
et ça ce sont des ateliers qui s'adresse
aux autochtones aux jeunes autochtones
en fait les deux en fait le au début
de la licence et est d'éduquer des
électeurs nos réalités d'octobre mais on
s'est rendu compte aussi que les jeunes
autochtones mener directement avait
envie aussi de se réapproprier le résume
donc justement on en a même dans les
deux milieux mais c'est vrai que pour
l'instant majoritairement c'est beaucoup
auprès des publics à l'automne qui ont
beaucoup d'ignorance par rapport aux
réalités autochtones et oui oui alors
vous m'aidiez à votre votre jeune enfant
en fait à votre enfant ali tout jeune
donc on ne sait pas comment elle va
vivre dans la société à quoi ça va
ressembler mais on va se tourner vers
isabelle parce qu'isabelle à des
adolescents des adolescents et des
adolescents wild girls
isabelle est ce que vos adolescents sont
tombés dans le code des skis ou alors
est ce qu'ils ont appris justement à ne
pas à ne pas tomber dans cette façon de
faire je vais parler plutôt de nos plus
vieux l'autre est encore assez jeune
mais effectivement à l'école ils veulent
dans une école hors communauté et il a
été victime de racisme on va se le dire
et pendant un bout de temps il est
revenu un moment donné un soir il était
en secondaire 2 il ya des mamans je
n'aurais jamais dû dire que je suis mort
qu et ça a été pour une maman ça a été
extrêmement difficile alors on en a
énormément parlé puis on s'est dit bon
comment est ce qu'on fait à partir de
maintenant parce que là il s'est dit
plus jamais je vais parler de ce qui se
passe dans l'actualité ou que je vais
démontrer un élément culturel
en fait c'est ce qui est en train de me
dire si je vais me fondre dans la masse
ça va être facile ils vont arrêter mais
qui aurait pu me dérangeait oui ça c'est
le fameux code là on est vraiment on est
en plein dedans alors j'ai dit est ce
que c'est ce qu'il faut faire
j'ai réfléchi moi même parce que quand
ça t'arrive à toi vrai que tu réagi de
manière instinctive mais quand tu dois
donner des conseils il faut quand même
réfléchir à tout ça et j'ai réalisé à
quel point briser le code demandait de
l'assurance demandaient du courage parce
que briser le code c'est en fait
justement à être soi-même socioculturel
mans parlant entre autres et ça dans une
société qui n'est pas la tienne ça
demande énormément de courage
et quand tu es fatigué quand quant au
pôle goût on a ou les mécanismes de
défense dont on parlait tout à l'heure
et de protection qui va faire en sorte
que justement on voit se former ou
j'appelais se jouer la game car je fais
plus jeunes ou se fondre dans le moule
avant d'appeler ça le code mais je
trouve ça très intéressant cette notion
de code lost c'est tout à fait juste
alors alors j'ai réfléchi avec mon grand
et je sais que tranquillement il
commence à faire les choses il trouvait
peut-être l'humour c'est un moyen pour
nous pour lui d'amener les choses
autrement
on ne fait je suis même allé à l'école
pour donner un atelier c'est pour
sensibiliser les autochtones sont
heureux parce qu'on est encore là on
essaie de faire ce qu'il faut pour que
et le mont jeune noah puisse s'épanouir
dans son école mais c'est un travail de
tous les instants il va devoir vivre
avec ça toute sa vie et prendre les
positions avec lesquels il se sent bien
je pense que l'important c'est ça je
pense qu'il va pouvoir savoir que moment
donné oui il peut pousser la barrière un
peu plus loin puis d'autres fois ci il
s'emporte il faut qu'ils se respectent
la dent puis qui qui qui qui se donne un
moment pour lui je pense que c'est ce
qui est important au bout de ligne oui
alors là je vous vois toutes les trois
vous travaillé très fort pour briser le
code
maintenant faisons travailler les autres
les non autochtones qu'est ce qu'ils
doivent faire comme travail pour ne pas
vous imposer un code pour briser le code
existant
je vais tendre le micro peut-être en
premier à maïté mon dieu moi je pense et
je pense que professionnellement moi et
je me suis refait à boubers comme je
sais tu entoure le fait que j'étais pays
moins que des personnes qui n'étaient
pas très fun je pense que ç'a déjà
reconnaître ou reconnaître
le savoir les compétences même si tu es
bon versus quelqu'un qui versus
quelqu'un qui est tout à fait le tour
des études en déduit de ce thalys je vis
dans ma culture l'histoire familiale
je pense que jean bon jeu mais même si
j'ai pas de chichis pas de diplôme qui
atteste ce jeu j'ai des connaissances il
sauva la puissa je pense que c'est cette
reconnaissance
cette reconnaissance le savoir est très
important surtout en milieu urbain après
bon moi c'est sûr que c'est sûr que des
fois aussi
moi je reçois beaucoup bond je reçois
beaucoup de choses sur les médias
sociaux des courriels un spa g de gens
qui me demandant aux orres une histoire
un vendredi si je peux leur expliquer
aussi je peux les aider pour l'heure
leurs devoirs des universités je pense
que tu es jeux de moyens beaucoup de
choses que j'ai apprises en faisant de
la lecture je ne suis pas née sachant
tout ce que je connais aujourd'hui je
pense que ça c'est important de
respecter nous respecter en tant qu' en
tant qu'autochtones et bon ailleurs
moment il ya un moment pour nous
demander des choses aussi mais si je ne
peux pas aider tout le monde qui
demandent de les aider pour faire leurs
devoirs
mais je pense que c'est important qu'ils
lisent aussi s'il ya tellement de bbc
radio 4
il sort toujours des listes de bons
livres d'auteurs et d'artistes
autochtones décrivait un autochtone à
lire et y est tellement de ressources
maintenant on lit je pense que si je
pense puis peut-être que ça force à
travers aussi le curriculum scolaire
d'encourager la littérature m'encourager
de d'encore d'encore changer ce que le
jeu donne quand même s'il ya eu un
groupe il ya un groupe de travailler là
dessus il ya quelques années puis des
ouvriers de laisser leurs formulaires le
curriculum n'est pas encore parfait puis
je pense que je pense que je pense que
le gouvernement vende devrait devrait
nous tendre la main et encore un peu
plus puisque vers souvent mais si elle
passe la peau confédérale parce qu'ils
vont y dix ans les autochtones cette
conférence c'est une compétence fédérale
de toute façon mais je pense qu'on se
sous-estiment le pouvoir des provinces
là dedans je pense mais bon je pense que
ça serait ça serait déjà à l'époque
voilà alors je vois lioui diable prendre
des notes je vais la laisser continuer à
apprendre c'est notre vaste tournée
isabelle isabelle et les non autochtones
qu'est ce qu'ils doivent faire comme
travail de leur côté mais j'entendais
maïté tout à fait d'accord avec ce
qu'elle dit mais ce que je réalisais
aussi c'est qu'au delà de ça ou
peut-être maman de tout ça c'est qu'ils
doivent déjà reconnaître qu'il ya un
code et ça ce n'est pas fait je pense
pour l'ensemble des non autochtones
justement ici à wendake et je m'en
venais avec un ami qui lui et non
autochtone et on discutait de
l'appropriation culturelle de racisme
demander qu'est-ce que je m'en venais
faire à l'émission et ont discuté de ce
fameux code là et il ne le voyais pas ou
à peine donc déjà de réfléchir à la
question je pense que ça va amener une
certaine ouverture de mieux comprendre
les choses
et peut-être que par la suite pour
pouvoir justement
et le jeu quand je dis on je parle des
non autochtones mais tranquillement
laissé l'espace le briser ce fameux code
là en intégrant bon peu importe où on
est mais en laissant les autres êtres
qu'ils sont que socioculturel m'en parle
notamment ainsi c'est à l'intérieur des
gouvernements mais pensez aussi aux
autochtones dans tout ce qui est fait
donc il ya plusieurs manières de fermer
l'ouverture bien sûr et comme on le
disait le racisme par un peu de
l'ignorance donc bien sûr l'antidote
c'est l'éducation et la sensibilisation
l'information je pense que c'est
essentiel oui dia c'est comme la grande
question quand c'est tout le temps posé
mais en fait je pense que dans ce
contexte particulièrement il ya quand
même un aspect écoute est considérée qui
est important écoutez les autochtones
qu'est-ce qu'il veut vider croire aussi
parce que sinon il ya cette tendance à
les croire ou peut-être minimiser
banalisée
qu'est-ce qui vais mais je pense est
important d'être à l'écouté c'est pas
parce que personnellement qui vit pas de
la discrimination du racisme que
d'autres personnes enlevées fait je
pense qu'un aspect écoute vraiment
important un aspect autour réflexion
aussi à savoir comment et bien que ce
soit qu'on peut contribuer justement à
ce code ne te faire porter bon cette
responsabilité-là à briser les codes à
ce qu'ils vivent
sinon ben bombe à la même chose que ce
qu'ils avaient pu m'arrêter 18,5 formé
puis différentes manières de s'informer
je passais important de encore une fois
pas faire porter le poids de l'éducation
et de la sensibilisation sur des impôts
tout le monde envie les gens de passer
30 dans son quotidien a indiqué sur les
questions autochtones
ce qu'on sait qu'on le fait de me canoy
parce que pour fliquer des organistes
qu'il fasse parce que chaque individu
autochtone pas envie puis chaque
individu et pas seulement experts de
toutes les questions d'internement de
repas québécois bon soit un expert de la
politique la géographie des ors de la
jeunesse québécoise qui va parler de
tout ça donc
c'est arrêter de faire porter ce poids
là aux individus autochtone et d'aller
soi-même maintenant avec internet c'est
facile d'aller s'informer sur les 14
octobre la vie mentionné tantôt avec
tout les médias maintenant à pitié un
espace autochtone sibylline de jeunesse
mais aussi parce que ça la littérature
autochtone c'est pas en fermant à les
lire des livres d'histoire minute
suivante manière d'aller se sensibiliser
aux questions autochtones puis donc son
ballet où c'était une petite coche un
peu plus loin le vraiment de réfléchir
comment au-delà de m'informer comment je
peux être allié ils ont osé autochtone
le réseau autochtone de montréal ont
créé un outil intéressant justement
c'est comment est ralliée aux luttes
autochtone puis enfin quid en fait il
existe un guide sur la question via sur
le média plein de doutes c'est très
simple maintenant avec tout ce que ça
les recommandations des commissions il
ya vraiment faire un moyen d'aller
trouver des pièces de son absolument
absolument d'ailleurs je le mentionne on
va bientôt recevoir pierre lepage pour
parler de mythes et réalités autochtones
ça aussi c'est un ouvrage il existe en
ligne maintenant qu'on devrait consulter
on se dit mais je connais pas voilà
voilà une ressource qui va me permettre
d'apprendre les réalités autochtones
voilà un merci tout les trois vraiment
ça a été très agréable de vous recevoir
j'en profite pour dire que maïté écrit
dans le journal métro des chroniques qui
sont toujours très inspiré ça aussi
c'est une façon de décoloniser les
esprits des gens alors je les invite à
continuer à vous lire dans le métro
merci beaucoup maïté labrecque saganash
avons très très agréable que vous ayez
accepté cette invitation et puis bonne
chance pour la suite merci merci à
isabelle qui est à québec isabelle qui
chronique aussi pour le journal la
presse
un là aussi c'est important d'aller lire
sommes toutes vos réflexions qui sont
importantes sur des enjeux importants
des autochtones d'ailleurs est ce que
vous le voyez les commentaires des
lecteurs de la presse est ce que vous
avez l'impression qu'ils sont à l'écouté
de ce que vous dites a tellement
tellement je rencontre des gens tout le
temps qu'ils viennent me voir puis on
aime ce que ce que on aime ça vous
entendant même sans entendre une voix
autochtone
c'est extrêmement motivant pour
continuer parce que c'est pas toujours
facile de parler des sujets disons
complexes que sont les enjeux
autochtones
oui voila merci beaucoup isabelle on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine merci et
puis merci à wedia la rivière donc
mikana on se tourne vers vous amis cana
pour en apprendre plus sur les réalités
autochtones aussi merci merci infiniment
la semaine prochaine tiens je vous le
dis tout de suite on va s'intéresser au
regroupement des centres d'amitié
autochtones il existe depuis 50 ans un
peu partout dans des villes à travers la
province
il ya un centre d'amitié autochtone à
montréal entre autres donc nous allons
en parler
le 7 février sur espace autochtone en
direct à tous merci et bonne semaine
[Musique]